not far from here with a Tory government
that waged war on its own people
brought up by my mum when the Tories
were attacking single mums with an
Indian dad when they said Britain was
being swamped by immigrants
they came for us
they came for our jobs and they came for
our community but we stood together we
fought together and we won together
but now they're at it again
so when your boss
earns three and a half million pounds
and gives himself a 32 pay rise and you
ask for a below inflation rise you're
the one to blame for inflation
and when you keep our country moving
during a pandemic
and then they cut your pay threaten your
job and refuse to get round the table to
discuss it you're the one who's supposed
to be militant
conference this country's problem isn't
militant workers it's a militant
government
and this is Tori Britton where the
foundations of a decent secure life have
been slowly eroded leaving us with an
economy we work hard for but doesn't
work for us where the contribution of
most people and most places has been
written off
so in towns across the country too many
young people have to get out to get on
taking with them the spending power that
once sustained our high streets and our
banks and our buses and our post offices
people are left to grow old hundreds of
miles from children and grandchildren
and our cities are plagued by Soaring
housing costs air pollution and strain
on public services
Now list trusts says her government will
grow our economy by turning the north
into Singapore on sea
so they can stash their wealth in our
towns and cities pushing up the cost of
housing and dodging tax
ing taxes for big corporations so the
rest of us can grind for a living in an
Amazon warehouse
handing 55
000 pounds to millionaires while people
can't afford to pay their rent feed
their kids and Heat their homes
more money for millionaires than the
whole of the north of England well I
agree with Liz truss about one thing
that is our disgrace
conference
it's time to stand up and fight again
not just to see off the Tories
but to build the country I've believed
in all of my life
where everyone can contribute and
everyone has a stake in our future
it will be about the real wealth
creators the women and men who clean our
homes work in our shops Drive our buses
and deliver our mail who produce our
food who care for our families who teach
our children who make sure we have what
we need to live every single day of Our
Lives to those people we say you are the
foundation of our economy
because we believe
that when people have a stake in the
outcome they work harder they try longer
they think more creatively and they do
more the people of our country are our
great untapped asset
and labor will tilt the balance of power
back in their favor
in our first hundred days in office we
will end fire and rehire we'll repeal
the anti-trade union act and will raise
wages for the lowest paid
foreign
a great rebalancing of Power with wealth
security and opportunity spread across
our whole country
because they say
power a modern economy using only a
handful of people in a handful of places
in one small corner of the country
we say that's like trying to fly a jet
on one engine this country doesn't
belong to a few of them it belongs to
all of us
so we'll invest to bring clean energy
jobs to the industrial and coastal towns
across Britain so that young people in
places that were once the engines of
British industry compare us through the
next Century like their parents and
grandparents powered us through the last
the road to Net Zero is paved with a
million good climate jobs and we'll
invest to bring them to Britain
and we'll empower
are brilliant leaders Steve Tracy Andy
Marvin Sean and all of our leaders
across local government with new powers
not for a few but for all to drive
growth in every part of Britain we'll
hand power back to our people with a
community right to buy to buy land and
assets the football clubs the historic
buildings and the pubs that make a place
a home
so that those with skin in the game
those who were in it for the long haul
will feel the whole system pulling in
behind them that Liz truss is how you
grow the economy
but if I've learned anything in the last
12 years of Tory rule it's that progress
is not inevitable
if you want to live in a country where
children don't have to go to school too
hungry to learn if you want to live in a
country where people with disabilities
can live the Richer larger lives they
deserve if you want to live in a country
where people don't have to fear growing
old without dignity and warmth if you
want that country you have to go out and
fight for it every single day
so I'm asking you
to get ready
because together with every person in
every place we're going to rebuild this
country from the ground up and I can say
to you today that in government I will
make it my priority to tackle the
housing crisis because nothing nothing
is more important than a home
tories have turned housing into a racket
incentivizing speculation and
profiteering while Millions languish on
waiting lists in cold damp homes
so we'll mend the deliberate vandalism
of our social housing stock because the
idea of a home for Life handed on in
common ownership to Future Generations
is an idea Worth Fighting For
Council housing is not a dirty word
[Applause]
now that we will be the first government
in a generation to restore social
housing to the second largest form of
tenure and this will be our Mantra
Council Housing Council Housing Council
housing
comforts
we're going to rebuild our social
housing stock and we're going to bring
homes back into the ownership of local
councils and communities with home
ownership owned up opened up to Millions
more
private renters we will tilt the balance
of power back to you through a powerful
new renters Charter and a decent home
standard written into law
because
Security in your own home the right to
make your home your own and most of all
the right to live in a home fit for
human habitation is non-negotiable
because housing isn't a market it is a
fundamental human right
it's tempting
at a time of national crisis to retreat
and to play it safe
that's not Who We Are
it was with ambition courage and
conviction in the darkest times that out
of the devastation of War we built more
Council houses than any government in
history we built the NHS the race
relations act the Equal Pay Act and the
minimum wage we rebuilt our Great
Northern cities From the Ashes of
thatcherism conference we LED Global
action on climate change and we flew the
pride flag above British embassies in
countries where love is a crime a light
on the hill at home and overseas and we
are going to finish the job
because we know
we are the only party that knows that by
the strength of our common Endeavor we
achieve more than we achieve alone
so conference
let's rise to meet this crisis in a
great National mission to rebuild our
country we have done it before
we're going to do it again
and we will do it the only way that
counts together
[Applause]
we've got some talent in the shadow
cabinet haven't we
think what they could do in government
so
um we're now moving on to the Scotland
report
um and for those of you who were here on
Sunday and uh heard shabana's excellent
speech about how we win
um she talked about the difficult
conversations that we have to have
um if we are to convince people to come
back to the labor party
well in Scotland we've had our fair
share of difficult conversations and it
must be said because we suffer at the
hands of two divisive governments one in
Westminster and one in Hollywood
but there is no root
to a Westminster labor government that
doesn't run through Scotland
so the progress that we are now seeing
in Scotland under anas and Jackie's
leadership should not be underestimated
hope has returned to the Scottish labor
party and I'm really pleased to be able
to Welcome to the stage now the one and
only Ian Murray
Jonah thank you very much indeed and I'm
delighted to be introduced as the only
rather than the last which sometimes
happens which is obviously something
slightly different it's a great pleasure
to speak to you today here in Liverpool
everyone says how great Liverpool is but
coming from a Scot you know that I
really mean it because the connection
between this incredible City and my
country runs so incredibly deep shared
values the same weather and the feeling
that a meal isn't a meal without
something that hasn't been deep fried
even just walking around Liverpool you
can be mistaken for thinking you're in
Glasgow and for a guy born and bred in
Edinburgh I think that might just about
be a compliment
of course the footballing success of
this city has been in partnership with
some fantastic Scots none more so than
Bill shankly born in airshow but made in
Liverpool
Kenny dog leash and Allen Hanson Legends
of the game even the current Scottish
national team captain and despite what
Ali McGovern MP might say there is
another team in this city especially
with the Scottish International
connections of the past like Alec Young
and of course the presence Nathan
Patterson
but there's something else
both Scotland and Liverpool have in
common and that is the desire to kick
out this corrupt and out-of-touch Tory
government
you would have heard our shadow
Chancellor reach your leaves in a
wonderful speech earlier this afternoon
when she spoke about the tourist
disastrous record in government her big
announcement that labor would fund the
acorn carbon Captain storage project in
Scotland it's absolutely transformative
there are few better demonstrations of a
just transition with twenty thousand
high quality jobs at its heart then
supporting this new technology it is
something the Tories have relegated to a
reserve list and at the last Scottish
labor party conference I called on the
SMP government to use their own just
transitions fund to support this cluster
but all we got from them was warm words
and no action instead the s p continued
to be more interested in stocking
grievance than storing carbon
conference I want to touch on just one
of the many ways in which the Tories are
failing our country
and that is by failing to protect its
very existence because the biggest
threat to the union today is really not
the s p it's this Tory government
and what was Liz truss's first priority
cutting Bankers bonuses and huge tax
cuts for the richest
HUD Administration is the most unfair
unjust and devices government in our
lifetime when she was elected Liz trust
tweeted or maybe mistweeted that she
would hit the ground
promise delivered
they give they give money to those that
don't need it and nothing to those that
do purified by those who can't afford it
rather than those who can
so it's little wonder that many Scots
see Westminster as Beyond repair and
make no mistake the s p Thrive of such a
disdain they don't want to make
Devolution work they don't want a labor
government
so conference let me be very very clear
the SMP are not our friends they exist
they exist for one reason and one reason
only to rip Scotland out of the United
Kingdom and please don't forget at the
last election Nicholas sturgeon herself
encouraged people in England to vote
green not labor
so let me reiterate here's message no
deals with the SMP none no need never
the only deal we want to make is
directly with the Scottish people
our party was founded by ascot
Scotland has been integral to our
movement that will never change of
course we can't resolve the imbalances
in our country overnight there's a lot
of work to do
but it'll be the work that will be at
the heart of the next Labor government
and that's why Kia asked Gordon Brown to
oversee a commission into the UK's
future
the commission is tasked with clearing
up and cleaning out the center so the
United Kingdom works for every part of
it you heard that from Lisa just a few
moments ago it would be a plan for
reinvigating economic Devolution where
we unleash the talents and contributions
of all parts of the country growth for
everyone everywhere wherever you are and
part of its purpose will not just be to
try to convince Scotland to stay as much
as we should but to make Britain such a
good place to be that everyone in all
corners of our country will want to be
part of it I'm pleased to announce that
Gordon Brand's critical work is needing
completion and will be launched in the
coming months and conference let's thank
Gordon Brown in his own words Gordon
thanks for all you do
so let's send a clear message from this
labor party to Scottish voters if you
want rid of this Tory government then
help us do it
if you want a UK government that works
for Scotland then help us elect one if
you want away from the binary choice of
Separation versus the broken status quo
then help us deliver it
and over the last 18 months the change
that has taken place in Scottish labor
is utterly remarkable and unprecedented
and the Scottish parliamentary election
we overshot expectations and managed to
prevent an SMP majority this may at the
council elections we beat the Tories and
got back into second place
and I believe at the general election
Scotland will help elect a labor
government as we have done so with every
labor government since Atlee in 1945. at
least then
and at least then I might have some
friends down on the train
depends who they are conference
the person that has made that happen
deserves every ounce of the praise that
he receives constantly he's our most
popular politician in Scotland and is
exposing the utterly deplorable record
of Nicholas sturgeon's government every
single day and it's always my great
pleasure to introduce my friend and the
leader of the Scottish labor party
anatsawa
thank you thank you
thank you very much thank you
conference can I start by thanking my
friend and not our shadow but our next
secretary of state for Scotland Ian
Murray
Ian I can make you a promise that at the
next general election we will get you
more colleagues I just can't guarantee
we'll get you more friends
and Conference I want to also take this
opportunity to contribute to and thank a
person that I honestly couldn't do this
job without our formidable Deputy leader
Jackie Billy let's hear it for Jackie
Billy
yeah it's it's somebody say she's the
real boss
and when I spoke to you just over a year
ago Scottish labor was a distant third
place and what progress we have made in
a year
at the council elections in may we
knocked the Tories out of second place
and just like successes we had across
the country we now have Labor
administrations in our Capital City
Edinburgh and east lovian east
rainbowshire Fife in Brooklyn North
Atlantic Circle South Atlantic shark
Sterling West Lothian and majority Libra
controlled Western bartonshire
foreign
Glasgow we gave Nicholas sturgeon and
the SMP one hell of a fright less than
200 votes from winning
but let me be clear
the Scottish labor party I lead doesn't
Aspire for second place we Aspire for
first place and we're back in the fight
and we're in It to Win It
conference last year we met in the
aftermath of One National Emergency
pandemic that exposed the fault lines
and failures in our country after more
than a decade of Tory austerity
but it also revealed the strength and
charity of our communities who pulled
together to help their neighbors in a
time of need
again and far too soon those ties that
bind us together have been called on
once again
this caused a living crisis is a
National Emergency that needs a pandemic
skill response and as I've traveled
around the country I've heard and
listened to those stories I've met the
father
worried about how he's going to keep his
home warm for his newborn
he's not alone
the mother who skips meals to ensure her
children don't go to school hungry
she's not alone
the family digging up their Garden to
plant vegetables because they can't
afford the weekly shop they aren't alone
the business owner hit with eye-watering
bills which means they aren't sure they
can stay open this winter they aren't
alone
this isn't a minority issue it's a
majority issue even people who would
normally see themselves as comfortable
are struggling to make ends meet
all the while oil oil and gas companies
are raking in billions of pounds in
profit and the Tories slash taxes for
those who need it least
because while Scots are struggling
neither of Scotland's governments are
doing anywhere near enough to help that
is why across the UK we demanded an
energy price freeze and a meaningful
windfall tax and in Scotland we call for
an emergency cost of living act which
would freeze rents band winter evictions
cancel school meal debt slash the price
of public transport and finally put all
the public transport back into public
hands
but given the choice both governments
prefer the comfort of the sound bite to
the difficulties of solving the problem
so don't believe the tourist spin there
is no Frozen energy bills bills will
still go up and families will pay double
what they did just nine months ago and
at the same time they're letting the big
energy companies off scot-free and
cutting taxes for the wealthiest
now for the last year labor of the
agenda on the cost of living crisis
while the SNP and the Tories tried to
ignore it all together
until it became clear they couldn't
labor called for energy price Rises to
be canceled our opponents called for
business as usual until they couldn't
labor called for a windfall tax on the
oil and gas giants the SMP sided with
the Tories and refused to vote for it
until they backtracked and with Scottish
labor called for a rent freeze the SMP
in the greens called it unworkable until
they gave in and introduced it
conference if this is what we can
achieve from opposition just imagine
what labor can do in government
for the last 12 years
for the last 12 years we've had a
touring government which is actively
sought to pit Community against
Community they wasted billions of pounds
of taxpayer cash on dodgy contracts
vanity projects and giveaways to party
donors they've got stamp Duty for second
homeowners and made super tax deductions
for the biggest companies they accept
poverty and misery as the price worth
paying for a society that redistributes
wealth but from the poorest to the
wealthiest
we were right to cheer the removal of
Boris Johnson because he shamed the
Office of Prime Minister
but let's be clear
Liz trust is worse than Boris Johnson
Boris Johnson
Morris Johnson didn't believe in
anything apart from himself
Liz truss is a right-wing ideological
story and Liz trust is more dangerous
than Margaret Thatcher let's be clear
let's be clear this is a corrupt lying
and competent failing cheating
economically illiterate morally bankrupt
shower and the sooner we boot them out
of dining Street the better
and the truth and the other truth is
that far from being the great Defenders
of the United Kingdom the Tories are a
gift to those who want to break us apart
in Scotland the Tories feelings have
allowed the SMP to double down on their
campaign of division rather than face up
to their own record of failure in
Scotland
more than 700 000 Scots on an NHS
waiting list that is one in seven
waiting for appointments and treatment
more than ten thousand children and
young people waiting for a mental health
appointment 20
000 fewer businesses in Scotland today
than when the pandemic began the highest
drug death rate in Europe and our NHS on
its knees despite the incredible efforts
of the workforce after 15 years in power
the SNP have squandered every chance
broken promise after promise and let
Scotland left Scotland worse off than
when they came to power in the first
place instead always someone else to
blame or something else to blame
conference you know you know what I know
there is nothing Progressive about
Scottish nationalism Independence goes
against the values of solidarity and
social justice it's an ideology based on
what divides us not what unites us
and Times of crisis should force us to
look with fresh eyes at the problems we
Face unite our communities and propose
real solutions ones that help us today
and build prosperity in the future
that is what labor is focused on
because why a lot of opponents thrive on
division we know the real change comes
when you pull together
but in Scotland and across the United
Kingdom our politics has lost sight of
that
I hate to break it to Liz truss or
Nicolas sturgeon whether you voted yes
or no whether you voted leave or I mean
your bills are still going up and for
too long we've LED we've been led by
parties which want to entrench us into
camps and convince us to dislike and
distrust one another
the conference
ask yourself this
who benefits from the politics of
division
it's not the families struggling to pay
their bills it's not the business
fighting to stay afloat it's not the
student working to achieve their
potential it's not the people trying to
buy their first home the politics of
division helps the Tories and the SMP
win elections and stay in power not to
change people's lives but it doesn't
have to be that way our politics can be
better our country is better our people
deserve better
because we in the labor party know we
can only win by bringing people together
by giving them hope not feeding their
despair
now we know there is a majority in
Scotland for being part of the United
Kingdom
but there is also a majority for Change
and crucially in Scotland and across the
United Kingdom there is a majority to
put the Tories out of Downing Street our
job Labor's job is to build the campaign
and the coalition to deliver that not a
coalition of political parties so let me
be clear no F's no Bots no deals with
the SMP but a coalition of the people to
beat the Tories
working with our Trade union colleagues
and all those who believe in a fader
Greener Britain it is our job to build
that coalition to win because ultimately
that's why we are here that is what has
motivated us to come from every corner
of these islands to this great Labor
city of Liverpool our task to win the
next general election is to end that
politics of division and demonstrate how
we change our country
because conference isn't enough that the
Tories or the SNP deserve to lose we
need to deserve to win
and to do that
we need to prove ourselves worthy of the
trust of that majority who want to renew
our United Kingdom so that we can
protect workers and invest in public
services unlock Britain's potential to
create the high-skilled paid jobs of the
future support struggling businesses to
actually grow our economy invest in
Green Technology to bring down energy
bills and save our planet and take on
the crony capitalists who rigged
politics in their favor and instead make
Britain a country where ambition and
Merit matter again that is the
difference labor will make and Power
for more than a decade the SNP in the
Tories have stalked up bitterness
Division and anger creating a politics
of US versus them
the conference we know those days are
numbered
so a message to the occupiers of Downing
Street and Butte house the clock is
ticking
so let's be prepared for what lies ahead
in the coming months and years our
opponents will get more desperate their
tone more irrational their attacks on us
more unhinged that's because they know
what we know the next electoral contest
will not be a general election and
Conference
labor will win the next general election
and Scotland's going to deliver the
seats to get us over the line
we will deliver the seats together over
the line we will help deliver that labor
government and we will help elect kirst
armor as the United Kingdom and
Scotland's next prime minister
because only Libra can replace the
Tories and change lives for the better
circumference believe
This is Our Moment to build a country
where everyone is entitled to dignity
this is our opportunity to set our
country back on the path to Prosperity
this is our chance to help everyone
achieve their potential the time for
divide and Rule is over the time for
change is now labor will deliver that
change and will build a better future
and we'll do it together thank you
here
thank you very much thank you
my Lord thank you thank you
thank you so much anas and not only do
we want here in number 10 we want Anna
as our next first minister in Scotland
have you said my name
so conference our next speaker is Peter
Kyle the shadow of Secretary of State
for Northern Ireland and he's just going
to update us on his important work over
there
thank you conference I won't keep you
too long I know you're waiting for the
football hero and Gary Neville
conference despite all the challenges
Northern Ireland is a thriving part of
our United Kingdom its creative
Industries go from strength to strength
entertaining and thrilling people across
the world
and it's a Powerhouse in cyber security
and financial services in Europe and
Beyond
but the politics of Northern Ireland is
hurting
the assembly and executive like dormant
The Divide between communities widens
progress has stalled this should worry
all of us and it would spur any decent
government into action
but not this one
for months after the Northern Ireland
executive collapsed there was no visit
from the Tory prime minister no
multi-party talks in Downing Street not
even a statement to Parliament
conference the biggest threat to
progress in Northern Ireland is not
misguided policy it's not even the lies
told by this rotten government the
biggest threat is Tory neglect
[Applause]
the progress is a labor government
the problem is the Tories see problems
as a chance for a row to deepen
divisions we see problems as a chance to
solve the challenges that hold us back
to create new opportunities and bring
people together
that requires a leader capable of
state's craft
who knows how to graft who shows people
respect even when sometimes they
disagree that's why I'm proud to have
Kia starmer as our leader
he has the skills Northern Ireland needs
to succeed
unlike Liz truss who creates more
problems than she solves
to imagine what labor can deliver for
Northern Ireland just look at what we
did deliver next Easter we Mark the 25th
anniversary of the Belfast Good Friday
agreement that totemic moment in time
when leaders from across the political
divides and communities decided a new
future was possible
it was only there to grasp because a
labor prime minister with his Northern
Ireland secretary believed in their
hearts that a radical change wasn't just
possible it was deliverable in that
moment
they put in the time
they brought people together
they pulled the impossible into reach
and provided the opportunities that
leaders in Northern Ireland and the
Irish government had the courage to
seize
conference We Salute those who made
peace possible with a labor government
we thank Tony Blair and the remarkable
one-off Talent of our MO molam
we also recognize the courage of David
Trimble who he said goodbye to this
summer and John Hume
they LED their communities into an era
defined by peace and growing prosperity
you know labor bequeathed the Tories a
Northern Ireland that was increasingly
at ease but they squandered it with
their lies and neglect it was the Tories
who proposed drafted negotiated and
signed the Northern Ireland protocol
into International treaty yes there are
problems with it but they can be solved
we know that negotiation is the only
path forward
but a year has already been wasted a
year in which politics in Northern
Ireland has stumbled and the Tory
government in Westminster looked the
other way
a labor government would deliver rapid
deals with the EU on the flow of goods
the sharing of data and making it easier
for agricultural products to move around
the UK UK and the Ireland of Ireland
will fight hard for our interests using
State Car Craft diligence and graft not
the Tory way which always somehow seems
to end up by breaking the law
the difference in approach and ambition
between the Tories and labor it couldn't
be Starker
labor delivered peace prosperity and
confidence to Northern Ireland the
Tories can't even negotiate a prawn
sandwich across the Irish sea
conference the people of Northern
Ireland they deserve better and with
kierstarma and a labor government they
will get it thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much Peter so before we
move on conference and
I'll ask for your Indulgence for just a
second because on this side at this
conference I've been on a mission uh
Jackie's a little cat passed away a year
ago
and she still misses her
so I've been trying to persuade her to
visit the sspca rehoming center that is
actually in her constituency
just to have a look
and there are a number of feline friends
currently in the rehoming Center that
need a home so if everybody thinks that
Jackie should pop in to the rehoming
Center this weekend Oh say I
thank you conference
um so we're going to return to votes at
the end of today's session but first we
have a very special guest or I know
you've all been waiting for and if you
can just stay in your seats and bear
with us for just a couple of moments
whilst we reject the stage ever so
slightly and I will leave you in the
very safe hands of our leader cure
starmer
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
foreign
in America
foreign
conference please welcome to the stage
Lucy Powell Kia starmer and Gary Neville
[Applause]
thank you
oh dear yeah
right get this
thank you everybody what a lovely
welcome a lovely welcome to care starmer
and Gary Neville so here look this is
Gary's first conference what does it
mean to you to have Gary here at this
conference this week well look it's
absolutely fantastic to have you here
Gary and you can see the reception you
just got I said to Gary this is like
coming out the tunnel at the beginning
of the game it's absolute you can see
the reception and you know and this is
Liverpool
give that to me that's what usually
happens in the pool
that isn't what I meant by Liverpool and
people think Sarah's got a thing about
Liverpool as you know but it's really
fantastic that you're here it's really
been noticed I think everybody
appreciates it and the points you've
been making the mirror interview you did
yesterday all the stuff you've been
doing today absolutely spot on because
the politics is spot on so Gary I'm very
very welcome
haha
[Laughter]
Gary how are you feeling about being
here what does it mean to you to cook
here for the I know you're a bit sort of
nervous with this political crowd but
you're all going to give Gary a great
welcome what does it feel like to be
here it's a privilege a little bit
daunting
it's the best reception I've ever had
here
[Laughter]
usually when I see Reds in Liverpool I'm
in big trouble
um no but it's great to be here
obviously over the last couple of years
I've chosen to speak out but I don't
believe staying silent is good enough
anymore particularly when we see uh
things that we don't like and that are
wrong and I have an audience and a
platform
and join the labor party last January
that Gary's the newest member of
Manchester Central CLP first time
delegates should have said yes first
time delegate
so here we are let's give it a go now
it's really fantastic Gary Randall
Applause
[Applause]
about UK or is it you're very very keen
on football and you play football you're
an aspiring midfielder is that right
aspiring thank you I can come up the
other end have you played a game this
week I've played the love I play every
Sunday which is fantastic I've just we
had a staff game last Wednesday oh
really
um uh which was very good but I think my
inner aggression came out sort of
battering people out the way trying to
get to the ball but it was fantastic
yeah with the staff team brilliant I'd
love to see that I mean Gary from what
we've got any advice for an aspiring
midfielder in uh what are his prospects
um
Everybody in the room who's ever played
with me speaking absolutely no chance
make sure you play Left of Center
Midfield yeah yeah
and you've got to deliver some nice
passes to that left wing because they're
a little bit noisy yeah
very good sorry yeah
look as someone who was previously had a
very big career before you came into
politics I mean what's your advice to
Gary should he come into politics I mean
or what's what what's your advice to
Gary as somebody as I know I think
that's being answered uh look what I'd
say I mean I came into politics quite
late I did other things obviously I was
a lawyer I worked in Northern Ireland I
was the director of public prosecutions
and I think coming in later in life
gives you something which you don't
necessarily have if you come in earlier
because it gives you huge experience
um knowledge of how to resolve different
situations also you know out there in
the world beyond the political bubble
most people see problems and their
instinct is to go and fix it and make
things better and we lose a bit of that
in politics so use the ex when look at
the experience you've got you know
Captain playing bringing people together
that is an incredibly powerful thing to
have in politics it's what we need in
our parties sometimes but not this
conference
um and but it's what we need for the at
the moment you know I think the country
feels very very divided we've seen the
true colors of the Tories last Friday
their absolute ideology came out you
know they're going to run the country on
the basis that the only thing that
matters is make the rich richer and
somehow one day uh some of that might
trickle down to other people so it's a
really big divide here there's a fight
to be had and you know you enjoy that
combo competition just imagine that the
Tories are I don't know Liverpool
Football Club
[Laughter]
who do you fear more oh I said that I
got asked that question actually would I
um Liverpool or the conservative party
and actually chose Liverpool which is
saying something
um
[Applause]
whilst we see football differently
people in Liverpool work hard they want
a fair and equal future they want
opportunity and belief and they are
aligned with I suppose mancunians and
the rest of this country I don't believe
it's just a northern issue this no no
definitely no it definitely isn't it
definitely
now just before we move on to some other
politics can we just have a moment on
the lionesses because what a summer that
was you went to a few games here
they were amazing and for someone who um
in 96 was in Wembley singing you know
football's coming home and it didn't
come home
um sorry it was there again
but I was playing a little bit awkward
yeah but it was
you know again we were trying to do that
and then this year it was brought home
by the lionesses it was absolutely
amazing and against Germany
that was a fantastic
but um I think my wife here and I went
with our children to the semi-final in
Sheffield and it was an absolutely
incredible atmosphere the place was full
it was really brilliant brilliant
football brilliant determination the
team were playing like a team really
together but what really struck me is
our daughter is 11 and she's interested
in football we're not that interested in
football and she was just Bewitched by
them she's absolutely I watched her face
as she was watching them playing
particularly at the end when they had
won and they were still on the pitch and
this was a a young girl looking and the
sort of aspiration to do it was there in
her and that's I think the the best
thing is you know that sense that this
is a brilliant game played by the women
we need equal access by the way we've
got to fight this fight for equal access
for women because the leg
I I just got to hold the trophies here
have you seen it I've not seen it I've
never seen the international trophy
well it's here and I went and they asked
me to hold it I thought blow me after
they've won it done all that hard work I
went up pick it up and drop it so Tony
Adams style
um but uh it was um absolutely amazing
what they've done but the Legacy should
not just be that in a cabinet somewhere
it's got to be young women having the
chance of equal chance to play football
I mean when when you think
the question gets asked sometimes why
should the men game fund the women's
game
and many of you will be aware many of
you may not be aware that in the 1920s
the men's game the fa stopped women
playing football for 50 years yeah yeah
and that's the reason why the men's game
now having set the women's game back so
far needs to invest heavily in the
women's game and there's a there's a
review at the moment
my mum was stopped playing in the 1970s
for a school team really yeah and my
brother obviously was the manager of the
England women's team for four years my
sister has fought for equal funding for
funding from sport England for netball
for many many years how can we be in
2020 still still fighting for funding
for equal pay for equal investment into
women's sports it's absolutely
ridiculous absolutely well let's hope
that's the uh
let's hope that's the Legacy just before
we leave football I want to just say
that
um and you'll have done this Gary I went
to anfield just two or three months ago
to go and look at the memorial
um to the 96 now of course 97.
um and it was incredibly moving an
incredible reminder of what happened
that day and I think inevitably just
because our children are the age they
are our boy is 14 he comes to football
with me and every time I went down the
list it's in rows and saw because the
age is on it the age 14 my heart just
stopped it was it's such a powerful
Memorial and that's why we've got to
change the law and we will change the
law to make sure that that never happens
again there must be Justice for the 97
and we will do that as soon as we get
into government
that's a really important Point here in
Liverpool this week and so talking of
regulation in football I know this is
one of your favorite subjects as well
Gary there's been some rumors this week
that maybe now the government might
backpedal on this idea of a statutory
independent regulator in football tell
us why it matters and you know why you
think that the Tories would be wrong to
backpedal on that well they would be
wrong I mean I'm surprised I have to say
because I believe that it's a simple win
for this trust and her government the
last election part of the conservative
Manifesto was that they would do a fan
LED review Tracy Crouch a conservative
MP has done a brilliant job with a panel
in bringing that fan LED review forward
with recommendations that I think are
appropriate for the whole game and it's
got cross-pathy support this isn't
actually a labor lived um conservative
argument actually everybody seems to be
on the same page because football clubs
up and down the country
so important to the fabric of the
communities around them and I have to
say I'm unsure as to where those rumors
emanated from last week I don't know why
you would even
think to Tinker with that because the
seats that are going to be fiercely
contested in a couple of years in the
general election a lot of those towns
that ultimately will be fought over have
football clubs in them and the efl the
professional game the semi-professional
game the supporters are all behind the
implementation of a regulator there is
only the elite in the Premier League
that aren't it's a little bit of a
representation of society vested
interest and greed will try and control
where the money goes and the reality of
it is it shouldn't happen in society and
it shouldn't happen in football yeah
and and care I mean you you always make
a point of going to some of these
football clubs when you go out and visit
so we've seen what happened in Berry in
Derby Wigan I mean what what do you I'm
not you know you've not said much
publicly on football regulation what do
you think no I go whenever I um go out
on visits I always try to go to the
local football club because the football
club is very often the center of the
town of the place uh a source of great
pride and a lot of them are really
struggling mcburry
um now back up and running but you know
Wigan there's so many examples of
football clubs that have struggled
because of the finance because of the
lack of an independent regulator and but
Gary's right Tracy Crouch's report was
accepted across the board you know all
political parties thought this was the
right thing to do independent regulator
the political will is there so if this
is introduced
um it will go through
I am concerned now with the change of
prime minister that it won't uh because
I think uh instincts I may be wrong
about this but I think her instinct is
um that anything that looks like
regulation anything that looks like in
another part of the forest taxation is a
bad thing and therefore she will pull
away from it so I think it's now more at
risk in the next 18 months or so to the
next general election than it was before
but we will we will run with it we will
run with it we'll push the government on
it because we need an independent
regulator and there is that consensus
there so I hope they push it forward if
they do we will support it and it will
go through because it really matters if
it doesn't we'll do it ourselves when
we've booted them out of office
fantastic okay
and what more um
what more can fans do can people in this
audience do to kind of push that cause
as well do you think I think right to
your local MP really important
um I think that would be the most
important thing that you could do and I
think you'll actually get support from
your local MP whether you live in a
conservative lib demo or labor
constituency you will get support
because they recognize it's the right
thing to do
brilliant right now we're going to move
on to a bit of politics
um I know that one of the things that
you two have bonded over over the last
few months was your should we say
diplomatically dislike of Boris Johnson
that you both mutually share so what are
you making of Liz truth so far then Gary
don't tell us what that's what you
really think
um
look the first thing to say is that
obviously she has the seat
and it's really important that we all
know what the end goal is saying when
you have a winning team you have a line
goals and that means you've got to put
your personal interests aside you may
not agree with every single current
labor policy you may not even agree with
certain aspects of what are going on but
you have to make sure that there is
laser focus in this next 18 months two
years to make sure that there is a
change this is a tired failing
government
it is and
when when you have someone either in a
football club in a business or in a
political party that are in power for
too long you get this level of division
tiredness they don't know they can't see
the wood for the trees and in terms of
this trust I mean obviously she's only
been in a couple of weeks it's been an
outstanding beginning hasn't it
[Laughter]
she's tanked the pound lower than my
reputation in Liverpool
I mean what what worries me is I know
that the tax cuts last week there was no
there was no high net worth wealthy
person and over 150 000 pounds a year
expecting wanting a tax break last week
but they got it
and yet they did it but that didn't
really tell me the most about them what
worried me not were worried with the
multiple what's told me the most about
them was that last week
in his new house went and knocked on
Lizzie's door and said what I think we
should do this week in the midst of a
cost of living crisis energy crisis
people worry about paying their bills
people worry about food I think we
should remove the cap on Bankers bonuses
how can you possibly in a million years
think that way I think they're the only
man and woman in this country that
thought that would be a good idea last
week
and
we're we're still we're still fresh in
the mind from the banking crisis 15
years ago
and yet they still went and did it and I
have to say that
there's this suggestion that you know
this trust is a is a new goals for what
she really wants but she was once a
liberal Democrat and she was once a
remainer
she's now a Tory and she's now a
brexiteer and I got told last week that
oh we got we got told last week I think
it was maybe that exposed it care that
the reason that she didn't give the
burden of the energy costs to the energy
companies because she once worked for
shell
I mean I mean on that I mean on that
particular point I saw also that they
froze the alcohol prices I mean do we
assume that she wants at a part-time gig
at Bargain Booze or something
so from that point of view I have to say
that the time has come for them to leave
office it really has the general
election can't come sooner
and
we can sit in here from whatever
background you come from
we were brought up by our parents and
our grandparents to know what right and
wrong was to know that you look after
people you treat people well and they
don't do that they don't do that
so you've got rid of Boris you actually
got rid of one prime minister how are
you gonna get rid of what's your
approach to Liz trust and getting rid of
her well let's just enjoy for one minute
that we have got rid of Boris Johnson
yeah
it ain't
we spent many hours talking about Boris
Johnson and why he needed to go and so
the moment he went I mean he did try and
cling on remember that last day his
resignation is coming and he's putting a
new cabinet together even more but he's
still hanging at the wings but look he
is gone and um now we have this truck I
mean he was all about character in the
end it was character that brought him
down she is all about ideology about
this ideology
um and it's very simple it is that the
way you grow the economy the way this
country go forward is about those at the
top that's why she thinks it's perfectly
all right to get rid of the cap on
Bankers bonuses I mean imagine saying to
someone this this this winter
um when they're struggling to pay their
bills what is the one thing that you're
going to do to help me pay my bill take
the cap off Bankers bonuses I mean
really
and what she did what they did last week
is this Theory and this is not just
funny for a afternoon like this this is
really dangerous Politics the dangerous
politics that really believes that the
people who create the wealth in this
country are only those at the very very
top and therefore if you make the rich
richer and the super rich even richer
than that that is the way that you grow
the country
it's proved not to work it's immoral it
leaves out of account
that those that actually grow our
economy are those that do the hard graph
day in day out those that go to work
those that drive the buses those that
drive the food people working in
factories in hospitals in shops
Engineers software engineers
store teachers those who work in our
hostels these are the people who
actually build our economy grow our
economy
and they deserve to benefit from the
growth in our economy and the Stark com
you know the difference now between
where they are the top only the top on
labor you know from the bottom up and
the middle out is so so important
although as I say that that does sound a
bit like my Sunday football I have to
say yeah
when you were preparing
mirror interview s today you asked me if
you could swear didn't you do you want
to just explain this because then well
yeah you ordinarily I would swear it
wouldn't be a problem for me but I
thought in a political audience can I do
that and so I actually gave the line to
the the mirror political editor I said
they are taking the piss this lot aren't
they
and then I thought you know
and then I thought I'm not sure can I
say that can I change it to Mickey take
the Mickey out of you not realizing that
actually Kerry had already used taking
the piss earlier
I can't be diluting my language when he
cares I've actually gone even further
yeah so you know it it generally is true
though isn't it I mean you know we get
to a point now whereby if you're a nurse
that's thinking of going on strike then
the accusation against you will be that
you shouldn't go on strike because
people will die because you're going to
go on strike that day not the fact that
it's been under invested in for 12 years
and that the fact that
when when you think of the people that
are working in education in transport
and nurses and in in in our NHS do you
think those people want to go on strike
it's their absolute last resort to have
to do that
oh
or do we just accept that people just
going to continue to not look after the
people who were clapped for 12 months
during a pandemic and now we're not
going to give what would be the sort of
if you like correct incremental pay
Rises too so for me I think we're in a
society now it's quite dangerous because
we have large parts of our media
that also support the messages against
our workers against people who to be
fair are trying to prop up our services
against this level of under investment
that's occurred we don't even talk about
health and education anymore
we don't even talk about health and
education anymore because they're off
the agenda because actually there is an
element of this government that in some
ways these crises that have occurred you
know pinballing about from crisis to
crisis they're quite not saying they
enjoy them but it gives them cover
against their level of incompetence
that's going on in the rest of the
country
I think
on top of all that they're now making a
bad situation worse because what they
did on Friday
was a massive gamble it's like two
gamblers in a casino sort of chasing a
losing run
but they're not gambling their own money
they're gambling our money and you know
when the markets react in the way we've
seen on Friday and then again today this
is not some abstract thing this is
investors who have investing huge
amounts of money who think that what was
said on Friday is really risky and it's
affected their investment decision this
is for Real it's not just one of those
funny graphs you look at you think well
I don't quite understand but it looks if
it's going down pretty pretty quickly
this is investors taking decisions that
are going to have an impact they're
going to impact those nurses those
teachers because this will mean mortgage
rates going up prices going up making a
bad situation even worse than it is and
that's why what was done on Friday
was absolutely the wrong thing
politically but it's also the wrong
thing economically and let there never
ever claim again to be the party of
sound finances never again never again
oops
try getting the funding proposal through
Rachel Reeves her fiscal rules are
absolutely like iron and they're that
that's the tenth breach of a fiscal rule
by them and the other thing let them
never ever claim again to be the party
of aspiration because they are choking
the aspiration of millions of people in
this country on the basis that they
don't matter it's only the people at the
top
so one thing people would see about you
Gary is that you're a winner you've been
part of lots of winning teams how do you
think that we can ensure we win that
next election and we change this country
for the better what would your advice to
us all here today be I think remain
laser focused and aligned behind the
single goal which is to remove this
conservative government and put
everything else aside and focus on that
alone that alone get behind
get get behind Kierst armor
absolutely
right
this is a serious politician someone
who's headed up a major department in
the CPS someone who is trustworthy and
has Integrity all things that this
current government don't have
and
and not not only this current government
damaging us in our country our
relationships and with our partners in
Europe and around the world are broken
and shattered and they've burned their
Bridges with our partners in Europe and
around the world and we need to rebuild
our relationships we need to rebuild our
reputation and that is not going to
happen under a conservative government
and here how how confident are you
feeling apprehensive complacent I know
you're not complacent because you
lecturers every week at the shadow
cabinet but you know how confident are
you feeling about the general election
we're just picking up on Gary there
because he's talking about the
international reputation this is true in
terms of we used to be a respected voice
internationally and we're not anymore
because of what this government has done
I think it goes even deeper than that
because I think what's happened in the
last 12 years is that because they
haven't delivered because they've made
promises that they didn't actually ever
meet or arguably ever want to meet or
intend to meet there's been a loss of
trust in politics a loss of faith in
politics a sense that politics doesn't
make a difference we've got to restore
that we've got to give people the belief
that politics is a Force for good and
make a change for them and so there's a
huge amount of repair work to be done in
terms of how we feel at this conference
and Gary I'm glad you've come to this
conference because there is a mood at
every conference you can feel it and the
mood at this conference is one of
confidence that we've done hard work in
the last two years to change our party
to remake our party to make it face the
public and that we're ready to deliver
and that sense that people are now
looking to the labor party for the
answers to the huge challenges that so
many millions of people face that is
what's here at this conference the sense
of coming together the sense that we are
really a government in waiting and that
we now have our chance at this
conference to set out our ideas for the
country that confidence is worth its
weight in gold absolutely
there you go
okay
so just before we go now the other thing
that I know Kia really likes to talk
about Arsenal and a bit of football okay
yeah
so only a few voices Gary what do you
think at the top of the league Arsenal's
chances of winning the Premier League
this season what do you think oh I'm not
sure about that
I've been quite supportive so far but
that's where it ends I think yeah
um no I mean I'm still doing very well I
think I like our tattoo a lot actually I
thought the end of last season when he
uh didn't qualify for the Champions
League I thought that would be a real
problem for him but they responded well
and they're going to have a pretty good
season I think that they won't win the
league City will win the league your lot
will win the league
unfortunately what would it mean to you
really if Arsenal won the Premier League
here come on oh it'd be absolutely
fantastic
um and no we're top we can still say
we're top of the league at the moment so
we keep but we've got you know it's a
brilliant team he's got really good new
silence I think who's the best who's the
best new signing well I mean I'd say
celiba but he's actually not a new
signing but it's his first season sort
of on the show for us but he's been
absolutely fantastic Jesus is brilliant
for us fantastic
um so you know let's hope it's their
season I remember you know the best
moment in football ever was here in
Liverpool in 89 when Michael Thomas put
that second goal in to win the league
for Liverpool for her [ __ ] it's
absolutely brilliant right got a couple
of last quick questions favorite
sporting moment of all time Gary
minor yes yours uh I will go with the
treble in 99.
[Applause]
oh but there's plenty of United fans and
Care was yours that was just brilliant
isn't it
the treble in 99. that's phenomenal Gary
this this is why we're so pleased to
have you it's absolutely incredible
um I remember last time we did this in
Manchester and we're just about to go on
and they read out all of your sporting
achievements and it's absolutely
incredible and I think tribute to you
for all of that and I wish we could all
sit up inside the triple it wouldn't be
so brilliant hello it's got I mean it's
that Michael Thomas uh goal in this 92nd
minute in anfield here in 89 absolutely
brilliant ended an 18-year run for
Arsenal absolutely brilliant excellent
right last question because we've all
got to go you've all got fringes to go
to this is fringes don't go yeah all
these fringes people keep talking about
Gary thought it was Fringe as in bad on
those lines yeah people sneaking away
and snidy talking they're like
so I'm going to tee it up for you here
now who do you think was England's best
ever defender of all time
well Gary's right up there but I've got
to say Tony Adams yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
here we go it will be clear when he wins
in a couple of years
right
that's it from us you've all got fringes
to go to parties to go to don't have too
late night can you all thank our guests
can you thank Gary Neville thank you
Lucy thank you
[Applause]
gosh conference what an afternoon eh
so and if people can stay in the hall
just a couple minutes more we've got
some votes just to finalize proceedings
today
if you can take your seats please
delegates
if if you are leaving
um can you do so quietly so we can crack
on
and it won't keep you for longer than
necessary okay
um first we have the reference back of
the Sutton and Tim
um reference back on the future where
families come first policy commission
report so can I ask for all those in
favor of the reference back please
and those against
um
sorry
okay so sorry about this colleague
someone's asked me to take the vote
again I I think there was still a bit of
murmuring as people left the hole so
um it's the reference back from Sutton
and team CLP on the future where
families come first policy commission
report so all those in favor of the
reference bag
and those against
um
yeah I think that is carried
[Applause]
okay so now